Determining what constitutes a mental illness can be a difficult task. Because
there's not a specific test, for example a blood test or an x-ray, that can
tell us which disorder a person may have. However, over the past 200 years,
many industrialized countries have categorized psychological abnormalities
using a medical model. The medical model is that conceptualization of
psychological abnormality as diseases. But like physical diseases have
biological causes, defined symptoms and possible cures. Therefore the first
step to determining the nature of a problem is through diagnosis. Before
discussing the process of diagnosing mental disorders, it's imperative to know
that psychiatric labels can have negative consequences, including negative
stereotypes. Or stigma. In fact, some research has suggested that nearly 70% of
people with a diagnosable psychological disorder do not seek treatment. We hope
that through this course we can educate you, as well as other students, in an
effort to help decrease a negative stigmatization associated with mental
illness.